do not go outside unless you're running
for a bomb shelter those are the orders
of a 35-hour curfew that is now in
effect in the ukrainian capital keep it
comes after russia intensified its
bombardment of the city on tuesday
striking several residential areas
before dawn
with deadly results
it's the middle of the night in kiev
those who are awake see the flash first
then
comes the blast
[Music]
one target an apartment block
authorities say several people died in a
series of airstrikes on residential high
rises west of the city center in the
early hours of tuesday
many have the rescue workers to thank
for being alive
we gathered our belongings and felt the
smoke coming we tried to take the stairs
to get out but the staircase was already
filled with smoke so we made a decision
to remain in the apartment
our kitchen was burning but thank god
the rescuers found us and they were able
to bring us down
russia's assault on the capital appears
to be inching closer to the heart of the
city
a weapons factory in central keeve was
also hit
but here as elsewhere civilians bore the
brunt of the damage
as the shelling intensified kiev's mayor
vitale klitschko announced a 35-hour
curfew extending through thursday
morning
and he warned the capital stood before a
difficult and dangerous moment
with a battle for kiev edging ever
closer klitschko appealed to all male
residents to fight
everyone who loves keeve and who wants
it to withstand must help as much as he
can
many women and children
have left to get to safe places
this is understandable
and many men who took families there are
back in the city
[Music]
but many key rights never left both men
and women
now some have to pick up the pieces
lucky to be alive but left with nothing
yeah these are some intense hours in the
besieged city of kiev i'm joined now by
kira rudik a member of the ukrainian
parliament it's good to have you
on the program this curfew is now in
force
what's the mood like right now
where you are and do you think people
have enough supplies to get them through
this 35-hour curfew
hello good evening thank you so much for
having me
so we have been preparing for a siege
both civilians and
the government uh in a while it's
actually have been since day one when we
want to surround the city and
starve us out
so right now
most of civilians do have the food and
supplies or at least were able to
prepare
and as for the ones who cannot provide
for themselves the city and myself
personally and there are many teams in
kiev who are helping out to make sure
that each citizen has at least like
three to five day supplies at home so
they wouldn't have to get out for
food
and honestly the coronavirus crisis
has taught us a lot so people have
supplies at home
as for the curfew that was implemented
we do understand that it is because
russians would most likely try to attack
and again we are ready to the ground
attack and people and events and
territorial defense resistance teams the
army we are training and we are getting
ready we are ready for the siege
uh and the city is now getting to be a
fortress what we are not ready for
is
the shelling and the missiles that are
coming from the air there is nothing
that you can do as a person to protect
yourself from the missiles from the
bombs that are coming
it's what is
makes me feel helpless and this is
what is makes it so hard on us miss
riddick let me just ask you about that
you know the fact that you don't have
strong air defenses and with this curfew
do you feel like you've been told to
stay indoors and
pray that you're not hit by a russian
airstrike tonight
well people are said are told to go to
the bomb shelters if they hear air siren
but yes the the feeling of inability to
protect yourself from this most
dangerous part from the ear
this actually is devastating and that is
why as a member of ukrainian parliament
as a leader of the party i continue
pleading to all our nato partners to
everybody who can hear to provide us
with a no-fly zone or a jet or any air
force protection so we will not be
sitting just waiting until the bombs
will be coming to our heads
if russians come in
let them come in we will be fighting
them we will be standing against them we
have been training for that we will be
ready but uh what if they will be just
trying to bombard and get the city to
the ground
there will be a very small amount of
things that we can do we can hide in
shelters and we can
you you know that
a no-fly zone is not nato says it's not
going to happen even if it were
it wouldn't happen in the next
35
hours that you're having to face this
curfew
uh you have not left kiev and about half
of the population of the city has also
decided to stay why are you still there
because this is my city and this is my
home
i wouldn't have another one and my
people my constituency is here and they
are all watching and they're looking at
me trying to find
signs of despair in me so to use it as a
reason to give up and i'm saying no we
are not giving up
we are fighting we are standing here
because we will need to protect the city
and we are protecting it and
no matter what happens we will be ready
to give russians a very very good fight
the way that we are giving them a fight
everywhere uh in ukraine where they
attacking and regarding the no-fly zone
i can tell you as ukraine we do have a
plan our plan is to fight russians and
our plan is to win are you planning this
route
what about you
do you have do you have a machine gun i
mean are you prepared
to actually if there's urban warfare are
you prepared to fight
yes i do have my machine gun and i'm
ready to fight russians and i have been
training along with my resistance team
that i put together and uh who is
training for the last 20 uh for the last
uh 20 days so i'm ready to
give them a good fight if necessary and
same as i same as myself there are many
many people in cave who are standing up
to the arms
kira rudick a member of the ukrainian
parliament ms rudik you're a very brave
woman we certainly wish you and everyone
in
kiev all the best tonight thank you
thank you and glory to ukraine
well the prime ministers of poland
slovenia and the czech republic have
arrived in kiev by train in what they
are calling a show of solidarity from
ukraine's european
allies
the czech republic's prime minister said
that the visit
is meant to confirm the support of the
entire european union for the
sovereignty and independence of ukraine
eu officials have voiced concern about
this trip and its security risk they've
said that the three leaders are acting
on their own and independently
uk marines president vladimir zelinsky
has signaled that he is ready to accept
his country
will not
join nato ukraine ruling out a future
membership of the western military
alliance was one of vladimir putin's key
demands in the run-up
to the invasion
ukraine is not a member of nato we
understand that we're decent people
we've heard for years that the doors
were open but we also heard that we
could not join that's the truth and it
must be recognized
i'm glad that our people are beginning
to understand this and rely on
themselves and our partners who are
helping us
well that was the ukrainian president
vladimir zielinski there
let's kind of analyze what we just heard
i want to bring in our correspondent
terry schultz she's in brussels it's
good to see you terry i mean those words
from zielinski it's a lot different than
what we've been hearing how significant
is this statement for nato and its
strategy towards russia
you know brent i think it's more
significant for ukraine itself because
as we've been discussing now for a long
time
nato did not intend to admit ukraine in
the very near future and that's why it
was puzzling to everyone why russian
president vladimir putin used this as
one of the excuses for his invasion but
i think it is recognizing the reality of
that for the ukrainian people that the
president was speaking about as for
nato's strategy when it is rejecting
moscow's demands that nato not enlarge
to take in even more members this is not
just ukraine that nato was talking about
this would also um refer to example
georgia which also wants in and and to
any other country that wants to join
nato in the future but i think that this
is president zielinski just readying his
citizens one more time for the fact that
this is not in the near future for them
if ever
earlier this afternoon
the secretary general nato yen
stoltenberg he spoke to reporters at
nato headquarters he talked about the
war in ukraine i want you to take a
listen to part of what he said
for months we have exposed russia's long
list of lies
they claimed they did not plan to invade
ukraine
but they did
they claimed they were withdrawing their
troops
but they sent in even more
they claim to be protecting civilians
but they are killing civilians
now
they are making absurd claims about
biological labs
and chemical weapons in ukraine
this is just another lie
and we are concerned
that moscow could stage
a false flag operation
possibly
including chemical weapons
terry you were at that press conference
analyze for me what we just heard from
stoltenberg
i think the most striking thing brent is
that he used the word lie over and over
i mean this is things that you hear uh
people use in normal conversation but
it's not the kind of stark language you
often hear from diplomats and
politicians and heads of international
organizations and i think that was was
very remarkable today and especially
that lap that last part where
stoltenberg was talking about the fact
that russia has claimed that ukraine has
been manufacturing chemical and
biological weapons this is something we
know that the alliance is increasingly
concerned about that russia may in fact
be readying a chemical attack of its own
and that's why you heard stoltenberg
here today and also in an interview he
did with a newspaper over the weekend
raise these concerns because they're
continuing this this practice of trying
to reveal as much of what they think
russia is planning to do as possible so
that it doesn't come as a surprise so
that it perhaps
serves as some sort of deterrent which
hasn't worked that well but in any case
we understand both from stoltenberg's
words and from officials that we've been
speaking to off the record that this is
something that is of increasing concern
for them they're on very high alert for
a chemical attack and a question about
the language that stoltenberg used today
he said that nato needs to
reset its military
posture
what does he mean by that
you're right to be reading between the
lines on this because uh he mentioned
some things very specifically putting
more troops uh along the eastern flank
more more pre-positioned equipment
holding more and larger exercises
reinforcing naval and air defenses as
well so for one thing this these are all
the the categories that russian
president vladimir putin demanded nato
back away from so they're reminding
putin that everything he's done has just
accomplished the opposite of what he
wanted but there's another thing at work
here brent and that is that there is an
agreement between nato and russia that
nato would not permanently station
troops on the eastern flank that could
be seen as a threat to russia the fact
that they're talking about now in the
long term resetting this posture means
that they they may consider this
agreement the nato-russia founding act
out the window because of what russia
has done so we'll be watching for that
in the future as well all right dw's
terry schultz with the latest tonight
from brussels terry as always
thank you
and here's a look now at more
developments in this war the european
union has launched a fourth round of
sanctions against russia
they ban investments in the russian
energy sector and they also bar luxury
goods exports to russia
and steel imports from the country two
fox news journalists have been killed
after their vehicle came under fire
outside of kiev the same attack also
left a network correspondent wounded
and russia has banned u.s president joe
biden and other top american officials
from entering the country moscow saying
the move is in response to u.s sanctions
you